hey everyone its Angie couch here and it
is Tuesday however for tie Tuesday we're
not actually going to be analyzing the
tie Tuesday dataset instead we're
actually gonna try to recreate a chart
from The Economist and this charts
called um if everyone had voted Hillary
Clinton would probably be present it's
available the silent majority and what's
really cool about the economists is they
have a lot of what really kooky charts
that are they really try to push the
bounds of data visualization and what's
actually really cool is they have a an
actual github repo that we can look at
so right here we can see the repo on
github and actually have a little folder
with their graphic detail data and the
reason why I chose a silent near
majority is because they actually have
the data set so we go all the way down
here we can see if everyone had voted
Hillary Clinton would probably be
present so that's pretty cool that we
have the actual data on that was used to
create this visualization and I think
it'd be cool to recreate this this
really almost cut it looked very complex
but we can have to do this in ggplot
pretty easily so I'm gonna go and open
up our and I'm gonna put this in a
markdown file I'll call this um let's
call it recreating the Economist this
okay so I'm gonna make this full always
load in the tidy verse and this time
we're gonna be actually going in and I'm
gonna show you kind of how you you pull
in CSVs from repos and you can do this
with I think most publicly available
repo so another good one is the John
Hopkins Cova datasets that you can look
at but for us we can actually look down
and read the main image was generated
using the included data file state-level
estimate with
so we're gonna go to a state level last
met with probs or probabilities we're
gonna view the raw data set and then
we're just gonna copy this link and
let's here we're gonna go here we're
gonna say ADF reader and then we'll say
read CSV well paste this in I believe
this is the whole estimate with prom yep
okay I almost do a basic glimpse first
all right so we have a state
abbreviation rep 2016 actual 2016
predicted totally V's rep mandatory dem
mandatory winner damn evey okay so this
stuff I'm not really sure what it's
supposed to mean
however we can go in and actually look
at the data dictionary that they given
us so state abbreviation that's pretty
self-explanatory rep 2016 actual actual
vote share actual vote so so alcohol
means actual vote share that makes sense
Fred means predicted poacher so that's
pretty cool
total V's is total of torille votes in
mandatory is I guess a model prediction
if everyone voted winner which means who
won damn Eevee how many looked or votes
one okay and then just basic predictions
dem so this this is also them predicting
I guess how many a look to our votes and
then how many look twelve votes given
that everyone was required to vote and
then also we have probabilities of
winning this state I mean when we
actually look at this visualization we
don't need this entire data set so if we
look at it it's saying okay so we need
that we need this states every state is
shown we see these these kind of ranges
which I'm not sure about right so let's
look at it and we can see right here
there's a little key right here so since
the entire thesis is basically saying
that when there's a higher turnout
um Democrats will generally win we can
see that
with everyone voting it's it's always
gonna go to the left it's always gonna
go to the left so that means like when
when we increase turnout more Democrat
more Democrats will more likely be able
to win that state so right the right
side is the original 2016 turnout and
then the left side is if everyone turned
out so you so looking at those you can
see oh wow like Texas it's it's so red
so 70 percent of likely two will go for
Trump however everyone turned out then
it actually about like six fifty-eight
percent chance likely to go to Hillary
Clinton and then you can see how the
blue is like right now they're they're
like if they're the right side is for
the colors is saying like okay so
they're going to be Republican it's
favoring Republicans the left side is oh
whether its favored to be that party so
just to summarize right side is current
just number of electoral votes so right
now if it's red it means Oh currently it
be favored to be a Republican if it's
blue I'll give this one to be favored to
become a Democrat and then if we force
everyone to vote then it goes to the
left side and we can see what it would
change so we can see how there's a
change from Arizona Pennsylvania
Wisconsin
however for say Ohio if we force
everyone to vote it would still say
Republican for Iowa still state
Republican and then it says mandatory
voting would help an aircraft's more in
Mississippi with more than any other
state because you can see that that huge
range so from 80 percent to almost 50
almost like 53 percent okay so that's
pretty cool what we're gonna need then
is we're gonna need an O state name the
state name we're also going to need to
know the probability of winning that
state and then probably win that say if
everyone votes so we already know we
need three columns okay lastly if we
notice some of these some of these boxes
are different I guess widths or Heights
depending how you want to view it
see how Texas is much
wider or larger than say Mississippi and
what they're also using is number of
electoral votes for that for I guess
2016 so Texas is worth a lot of 12 votes
and it's saying that oh wow if everyone
voted in Texas like Texas is the main
dog that we would probably focus on if
we were gonna try to do some type of
huge focus turnout thing i turnout
campaign whereas if we really want to if
we did a huge thing where if a
Democratic consultant said okay if I can
decide between any state to basically
force or require some Australian style
mandatory voting it would be Texas it
wouldn't be Mississippi and it wouldn't
be say California it'd be it'd be Texas
because it's worth a ton of votes that
crosses the line lastly one thing that I
really like about this visualization is
one there's there's a lot of it is a
really it kind of seems almost like like
a chaotic chart but um The Economist
knows that people are gonna spend some
time looking at this and it does
actually look pretty organized right so
we we have this main chart we have a
nice key that explains a chart we also
have these nice little paragraphs kind
of kind of help explain on the thing was
a little disclaimer saying meaning to
browse for trade as if they gave all
their electoral votes it's a white
winter even though they don't they do
I'm like I guess like proportional
voting and then they finally had this
where is just a basic summary of this
entire chart so it's kind of a chart
within a chart where it's saying okay
actual result simulation with 2016
turnout and then if everyone vote it you
can see the the basically change and
that that's the whole thesis okay so
that's a lot of talking for something
that we've only needed four things right
and what's really cool at this is like
The Economist bassy the best news
publication for data visualization so
they always do a daily chart um or
graphic detail article which just does
an article about data visualization so
they're really good at it and they've
been doing this style for a long time
okay so let's go back here
here so while we need what we know is we
need to select state abbreviations or
the name right notice how there's what
51 rows i we need to know their
electoral votes
so total EVs 2016 and we need to know
the Devyn probability we need a we need
to know the probabilities so we have
probability mandatory and we have Devyn
probability 2016 I missed which more
round so don't get confused and we're
what we're gonna do actually is this
entire thing it's kind of a long thing
so we'll just say let's call this one
probability what color probably will say
prob equals 2016 probability that a
democratic will the Democratic candidate
will win that state and will say prob
man equals dem probability for mandatory
okay so I think we should do some basic
data cleanup so I think for a
probability problem and we need we
should change it to like actual
percentages because if you look at our
chart right here it's in it's in a
percentage format or it's or you could
just say it's not in decimal format so
let's just remove it from decimal so
we'll say mutate ATS and then we'll say
FAR's contains and we'll save prob so
what does it say it's saying like we're
gonna only mutate at columns that
contain the word prob okay and we'll
just do a little function will say times
100 I think that's how x times 100 this
is basically just kind of like a I think
a custom little helper function I think
that Python equivalent big old lambda or
something like that so boom we did that
so it's saying like okay any column that
contains the word prob
we're gonna take that call which is
basically a synonym for dot X and was
multiply multiply it by 100 okay cool so
if we did that we can see how like DC
has a hundred cent probability of being
wanted by Democrat let's let's just do a
validation or
you check on it oops so DC all the way
down there harm % that makes sense we
also get Utah Wyoming West Virginia so
let's look at that
okay so Arkansas Arkansas has like a
zero percent it has zero percent so this
all makes sense
nothing Crazy's goin on okay so now
let's just do a basic ggplot okay and I
know you're thinking like okay Wow how
do you how do you mean start with this
chart this starts crazy oh yeah that's
me insane but what we know is we can
just divide it in basic add a basic term
right so we know that all the states are
on the y-axis so let's just which is for
that first so with a s aesthetic y
equals a state abbreviation and what
actually we'll just say let's do the
x-axis first and we know the x-axis is
probability but we don't know what is
what so I think the best thing is well
let's just start basing so oh it's just
part of the probabilities where y equals
state abbreviation and let's just do a
genome line right cool so that's not
gonna obviously do anything cuz we're
having it grouped as state however we
can see that it is like almost like a
box plot it's not about it's like on a
column chart but what we do see is we
have the probability of what 2016
turnout and we have the probability one
voting so what that means is we could
actually kind of do something like a box
chart but we can just simulate these as
as a lines right because we don't let's
just ignore the widths of it or the
number of electoral votes and we'll just
we'll just call this has a line which
means you could just do a genome segment
so what GM segments you specify the X Y
X and and Y ends so we already have our
x and y so we'll say xn equals table man
and yn is the same thing which is a
state abbreviation so let's just do that
let's see what that looks like okay what
do we notice here is that it looks
terrible because it's not in a formatted
way it's not formatted in a what they're
doing is basically by doing it by
probability right because it's saying
like the ones with the highest
probability of being a democratic state
or winning being won by Democrat is
Cheadle is to the bottom and the one who
has the highest probability of not being
a Democrat or being a Republican is to
the top so what that means is we got to
do some reordering so let's mutate and
then we'll say a state abbreviation
equals reorder and we'll say state
variation and I'm not sure if it's if I
don't I'm not sure which probability it
is yet but what we can do is we'll just
assume let's see here
let's see let's see let's just assume
it's with 2016 sure know why I'm saying
that is it seems like though the hmm
trying to think actually let's let's
assume it's it's with everyone voting
because I didn't see the right side
there's some overlap between Georgia
Florida and Michigan however if we look
on the left side it's almost it's a
staircase there's nothing there's
nothing it's not like there's no little
divot right so it follows this little
staircase thing so we had that with
mandatory voting okay
so let's do that reorder by Rob and okay
so now now you see here it's looking
good it's actually looking like it makes
sense right now it's sort of kind of
resemble almost a skeleton of what we're
trying to make right except we have one
problem
okay so we have DC at the top whereas
The Economist chart has Republican
favored states on the top we do this
pretty easily by
you just using a scale X scale X reverse
what this does it just it just reverses
it oops what is doing CL X reverse the
scale extraverts reverses it so now we
have so we have Utah at the bottom
that's not what we want and we have DC
on the top how about how about we do -
and then let's see what's going on ere
we go
so as we eat see there's some kind of
like messing around we're like basically
it's taking like the inverse of an
inverse and that somehow just kind of
flips it in a correct way
okay so always plotting is like it's
just kind of just kind of just guessing
and checking messing with minuses
descending orders and other reversing
but we do have a skeletal framework of
it this thing this thing is looking
exact very close to what this - what the
economists chart is okay all right so 0
to 100 ok hundred percent likelihood
boom so we actually yeah that makes
sense
I'm stone likelihood be a Democrat zero
parallel is your percent chance of being
a Democrat okay so now that we have
genome segment let's just put in the
size now what's cool about Jim's segment
is you can actually specify the width of
the each segment because this is this is
technically oh it looks like online but
it's really just kind of like a box so
if we do size equals 20 it's gonna look
very weird right but their boxes notice
other boxes instead of lines because
they're so small that we actually didn't
know that they would take lines okay so
we can change these sizes but we kind of
don't want to do that we wanted to do it
per almost like programmatically so
we'll just say
Oh size equals total EVs 2016 okay so
notice how somewhat they're they're
different sizes right where Texas would
it be is is a lot larger than say I know
however I'm not really I don't like to
look up this piece I want them to be a
little bit a little bit wider um so
maybe I'm just gonna take I'm gonna
emphasize if I just sang log 10 of state
oh not all accounts Dave all do uh come
a log 10 of that okay so there we have a
little bit yeah I'm not not too happy
about this but it looks it looks fine
for what what it is right now we did we
based want to it's not so emphasized so
maybe I can do like a 10 time 10 times
log okay that's not working mmm 10 times
long how about 10 times I don't know
it's not it's not only a big deal I
think you can definitely play with this
a little bit more I'm gonna remove the
legend The Economist never really uses
like crazy legends they use like
customary legends and I'm actually gonna
ignore this we're gonna focus mostly on
this stuff okay so now we have this
chart with the sizings
and stuff like that it looks fine it has
a little staircase so it'll approach
with it we're gonna just add that that
nice little vertical line so we're gonna
say Jim um was it HV line V line where x
intercept equals and it's 50 boom okay
so we have that um also we kind of need
to have the colors so I'm gonna I
actually have the that the pattern
colors that they actually like kind of
upload for you so just looking at these
colors we can kind of look at it and say
okay
sure I think I think that's like a
turquoise we let me see your okay maybe
okay so we'll use turquoise I think
that's fine
one other thing little trick you do is
you could use the snip tool we can kind
of take a sample of it get the color and
then we have our our hex color so let's
just do that we're gonna do that it
probably won't be perfect with with a GD
plot so we're gonna do that okay so with
these segments we need the color to
equal and you always use a like a little
number sign cool so now we have these
things additionally notice how it's a
white background so to get a white
background I'm just gonna do a plus
theme in a mole okay we removed most of
it we got our removed also the I believe
they're the vertical lines so scale why
I think discreet and we'll say what is
it
break break line breaks equals null cool
so now we have no line breaks on it will
also do legend dot position equals nine
why is this thing so on here okay I'm
just gonna
okay so we have this notice how the
vertical line is behind these things
it's just cause like ggplot is
essentially a stacking each each little
command on top of each other so if you
have genome v-line on as the first
command then everything else will be
stacked on top of it okay cool
I'm not sure Oh me will say we'll just
remove all the X labs and wives first
actually we want to keep yeah we don't
want to live any other labs yet okay so
we moved all of this okay and then I'm
gonna try to remove that log10 thing
theme legend position equals nothing
okay sweet we remove that and then we'll
say labs title equals I'm just gonna add
like kind of that the generic thing so
we'll say silent majority the silent
majority so the silent majority subtitle
equals if okay if everyone all right
if everyone had voted Hillary let's see
I think that's the title Clinton would
probably be - and president okay I don't
know this session yeah I think I think
it's gonna stick with one line so I'll
call it actually I'm gonna look it up
first line break in subtitle on TV
bought
okay I don't want to do that look at
that that's a lot of work for some that
doesn't really matter okay cool
so silent silent near majority cool okay
I'm gonna make was it let's see I should
probably do some yeah some things so
element I'm just gonna change the size
so element text as equals was it 16 may
be silent near majority okay and we'll
say the color equals and we're just
gonna use the The Economist read that
there that they're giving us so it's e e
whatever that is okay okay cool
silent near majority and then we'll say
a lot dot subtitle element text size
equals and this is the big one so let's
say it's like what 24 call that and I'm
not sure if I if you're go ahead vote in
uh try and think I think maybe we could
leave it but actually I want this thing
to be a little bit silent near majority
okay
also I'm gonna use this use this package
called a library extra font um so that
way we can do some little font work and
what this does is we can basically add
in our fonts that we want to add so for
example if you notice this is this these
this subtitle has like little feet on it
which I believe is called a serif font
so we're gonna kind of say that we're
gonna say I think it's family equals and
serif know I don't really have a lot of
fonts because I don't really mess with
fonts but I do have Times New Roman so
let's see if that works
it works perfectly great so now that we
have our feet a little feet things on
the on the bottom we have a little red
text on it I think when we look at this
full screen everyone who a Quentin would
probably be present okay we're gonna
we're gonna arrange this with we're
gonna Center it I
that's just HS equals 0.5 and then we
will Center the other one too so HS
equals 25 boom perfect so you can see
here we are we're right on our way to to
doing a pretty cool chart okay now we're
gonna have to add in let's just what
just messed with the No Labels a little
bit more so we'll just say was it was at
breaks or I think it's break breaks
equals C and we'll just call it 0 10 20
30 40 50 80 there's definitely a faster
way to do this I like probably repeat
100 but we want to witness we want to
say that we're gonna count by increments
of 10 and then finally we'll do labels
and we'll say 198 and it goes right back
up
okay cool we're saying is okay so what
it does is like okay once it's 50% that
means it's even so there's equal chance
of 0% I mean at 50% 50 and then when
it's increases it goes to 60 percent in
favor for Republicans great so I'm just
gonna kind of separate this into three
main things we have our data wrangling
so I'm gonna call it data wrangling our
actual what plotting so plotting and
then we have like a form matting right
so we have that all right finally oops
all right finally we want to start
adding these these right and left little
colors that that's what makes it
actually look really nice so again since
we already have genome segment well just
use it again because I think this will
actually add on to what we want so genes
segment except this time we kinda just
want to make what I'm think about is
we're just gonna make the same i'm
dimensions of this segment but we're
gonna cut it so it's just a little
sliver okay so first let's just start
with the 2016 turnout so instead of
doing this entire having a width of this
entire range we'll say it's the width of
the start - a little bit right so we'll
say prob and we'll say -1 and just to
make sure it doesn't do anything crazy
I'm just gonna say red just as see if
it's working sweet right so now we have
we have read we have read a little
labels on okay so we're not gonna
actually say it's read you we're not
gonna actually just like manually say
peas right here it shouldn't be read it
that's that's not how it works but we're
gonna do it just for formatting purposes
so we can remember it so then we'll call
this blue okay blue so instead of
instead of having on on the right side
we got to do it on the left side with
everyone voting and so it's we know that
xn is problem and we'll say prob man and
instead of doing -1 because they don't
go outside the space we'll say plus 1
ooh problem and x and x equals oh and
we'll say alright since what it's doing
is it's actually saying oh well since
you didn't specify an x value it's just
a new prob and we no prob and prob
manner separate each other so we have to
specify our X for this one so we'll say
prob man dope and we have we have this
it doesn't make any sense and it's
violating a lot of the rules that we
want to put into it but it's doing what
we want it to do okay and that's
important
so now well I'm thinking that we should
need to do is we need to do some like
some some some some logic for it
so our logic for this thing is saying if
2016 turnout it's greater than
probability if 2016 turnout probability
is greater than 50% then it should be
red so let's do that so we'll say mutate
and say prom grand equal to 50 then it
should be red and our red we're gonna be
a little consistent and say our red will
be this guy okay ooh
and what color will call it um prob
we'll call it right color just so we
just for ease I just for readability
sake so if else
Prabhas greater than equal to 50 then
we'll put in that else we're gonna have
a blue and this time let's look at our
little paint like what is it our color
and we'll say sure we'll see that mid
and that the bucks way bluer so yeah
well she just
we'll just uh oops we're gonna zoom in
what I want to I want to grab that blue
so I'm gonna do a snip of that boom
we're going to open up that blue and
just kind of sample it boom
zero zero nine three one being don't
know why I said I have it saved
okay so else oh no what oh god some
reason it did not save that that's Roy
knowing so we're gonna go back to it do
the same thing okay I bet I think if I
if I close it it might just like cancel
it out but I also don't know what I'm
talking about and so okay boom okay so
else I'll beat that so now we're going
to test this by specifying the right
color the color equals right color so
color equals right color and we're gonna
remove this and see if it's working
what's going on here oops
there we go yeah that's that's what we
want I think that blue looks a little
odd but we're gonna keep it we're gonna
keep it we're gonna keep it okay so now
we're gonna do the same thing and you
can do it in the same you could put all
these move tape functions in the same
area I'm just gonna do it just so we can
look at it a little bit easier it's a
left color and this instead will be
instead of probability since we want the
left side it's the it's the probability
of the mandatory right I'll probably
admit I'm probably mandatory and we'll
say left we'll call it left color so
we're gonna again remove that and say
color equals left color and boom we have
it we basically have everything we
wanted so I'm gonna I can finally delete
that stuff gonna save okay so we have
this we have a chart it's looking really
great right might have to remove these
minor breaks so we remove that I think
it was minor
how do let me look up remove minor
breaks G teapot vertical Mons scale X
but what about minor breaks panel main
okay I think it's that so panel dot grid
dot minor dot x equals was an element
link element blank run it sweet so now
we have the minor breaks removed solid
okay
finally I will not be adding the arrows
partially because I don't think it adds
as much and also I'm not sure if they
I'm not sure if they actually use Gigi
fall for this they might have used the
illustrator but the general idea is that
like no none of these states increased
probability of winning for Republicans
right so we just ignore that we don't we
don't even worry about that okay but
what we do need need to know is we know
which stays like what this is what bar
represents a state so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna add a state name so
we'll say label equals state and then
we're gonna add gym text yes and x
equals they have it so they have it kind
of everywhere I think they might have
used like a different type of genome
text package that's specially that can
like basically look at it and find out
the best ways I put it instead I think
the best way for us is we're just gonna
put on the left side so we can read the
left side kind of see differences
edition you um you clip it on the right
side the only reason why I kinda don't
want to do the right side is cuz then
you're reading from like yeah from like
right to left you know you're really
supposed to like kind of read it right
from up you can see how like oh all
that's going left so it would kind of
make sense to look at the safe room with
that well you can do both ways you can
do either way definitely I don't think
it really matters I'm gonna do it on the
left but it's very easy to do on the
right and in fact I might just switch it
around or do you both and decide which
one I like the best that being said we
know we need to put it on though I'm
gonna do it first on the left side so we
need to specify our labels X and Y axis
points we know the left if we look here
we can see oh our left color is problem
and so we'll say problem and y equals
state state AB
and well let's just say the color equals
black okay
boom we easy as pie we have it it is on
it so we will do a I think it's a nudge
nudge I'm not sure if this will work
nudge one okay it does so we're gonna
nudge it by a little bit nudge 1.5 we're
just gonna nudge it to the left a little
bit I'm gonna do it 7-5 7-5 okay okay
maybe it might be 1.9 I really don't
like how that thing is there but I think
we might have to leave it I'm gonna do
two to just to make a little pretty okay
so we have it all to the left we're
gonna add another GM text and this time
it'll be to the right so we we know it's
prob and we'll say 7 nudge minus T we'll
say plus 2 and I forgot the plus Oh No
let's see what's going on x equals Oh
prob there we go
and then BAM we have it on here you know
I am gonna make this decision and
putting it on the right side so see
adding the actual text labels is pretty
easy I'm gonna do it on the the the
rights just because you're gonna read it
kind of from right to left so I'm gonna
just remove that actually I'm gonna I'm
gonna comment this out so boom and say
left labels boom now I have on the right
we have to do a little bit more
manipulation so I'm going to to point to
is there's some overlap on them it's
taking a little while some reason
let's look at it finally see these
little annotations we could add well I
got the GG a note 8 I'm not sure I did I
think they're like arrow bars for
something like that okay what is going
on here oh yeah I'm gonna stop okay
we could do an annotation on it I I kind
of don't want to additionally what we
should do though is add a Hillary
Clinton more likely to win Donald Trump
more likely to win things right here we
could I kind of do like that Florida
thing so we might we might do that too
okay
okay what's up with my art console huh
okay we got it we got it
everything looks fantastic so now we're
gonna add some annotations I know
patience okay so right here we should
probably put it I don't know where
Wyoming is so you know okay what is it
I know okay and I think the genome evils
can you text write x equals we'll say 60
y equals W y label equals test right no
right okay I must have done something
weird on it so I'm gonna sue no I don't
want deal with this chunk so I'm just
gonna copy and paste to enter this other
junk okay what is going stop don't write
oh wait okay just say hmm very
interesting okay well I'm just gonna
okay oh I think I have to specify the
thing where I just say let's see if that
works
okay for some reason my things being a
little messed up so I'm gonna run it
into another console and we'll just do
that there we go
we'll put this guy right there okay
we'll sit that out
it won't enter that okay hy is not found
so I have to let's you think that's how
it works right okay so we got to make
this a little bit smaller and that this
is why I really do not like the the
annotate function to be honest because
it's easier just just to do this in
Illustrator cool so we have test okay
and we'll say what's the what's the
thing called Hillary Hillary Hillary
Clinton more likely to win oh we said
line break and a note AGG why
oh that that's why okay so we're gonna
put this guy right there
Hillary Clinton more likely to win and
we'll say family equals Seraph Hillary
Clinton more likely to win and we'll say
color equals what's the what's the the
blue thing we're using right now I think
it's this one
so was a color equals that cool we're
gonna exports a little bit okay Hillary
Clinton more likely to win and then
we'll do another a note a text actually
what is text Donald Trump more like to
win color equals a is a little red guy
over here and then in this case the y
axis will be was it 8000 was it 40 40
don't try more likely to win cool great
I think I think that's it maybe I'm
gonna do a little bit more formatting a
note a left-aligned G pot maybe maybe we
can do a left online for the text I
would be 8 that'd be kinda nice H just
equals 0 seems pretty easy so let's just
add it into it H just equals 0
it's just equals 0
well I can wait and then we ought we got
a change this thing little min so will
more likely to win Donald Trump more
likely to win I think the size could be
a little bit bigger so we'll say size
equals 12
does that make it huge that makes it
ginormous size equals probably probably
maybe 6 so let's do size equals 6 size
equals 5 okay and that size equals 4
that's the same size size equals 5 in
size equals 5
let's see o and H just equals maybe
we'll make this kind of like because
they're like you know back-to-back with
each other so H s equals 1 and then
we'll make this 60 I'm gonna make it
actually a little bit closer to each
other wait 60 at 70 no it's up 50 55 and
this one would be 35 or is it 45 great
sweep um lastly what we're gonna do is I
am actually gonna do the the line break
if everyone had voted Hillary Clinton
would be President so after Clinton was
it
so after Clinton - and we're probably
and would probably be an n - n
if everyone had voted for Clinton if I
have voted for Hillary Clinton oh it's
not and yeah boom um I think Catholics
that looks like a nice chart right um
yeah I think that's it um I would
probably the annotation to someone else
but yeah here's here's a code um when we
say data I'm gonna just do some
commenting on it data wrangling the
plotting the annotations formatting so
as you can see here these are lines of
code it is a lot it looks very long but
a lot of it right was just formatting if
we look at the actual GD Potts it's it's
really just uh um what is it a five
liner for the plots some annotations
some some formatting some really basic
data wrangling which honestly was mostly
just for formats so I'm gonna do this
and I'm gonna put this right here yeah
oh yeah and you can see here it looks
very very very close to it I not sure
let me actually let me make it whit's a
little bit log ten sighs sighs so the
only thing I would really change is the
widths of it but again it's not bad to
look at again you can also add arrows to
it yeah I'm gonna fullscreen it and yeah
here's our work didn't take too long to
do and I'll see you guys next week so
Teddy on